we just retrace this story right so you
do basis you you have this idea for a
stable coin you end up giving back the
money when you decide it's not going to
work you um this new new idea for for a
decentralized social network you raise
some money from legit hitters other
people pile in like you're saying it's
all pretty
quote unquote fair which is that we're
all owning the same thing
and um
and then you get to the point of the
launch you're you decide to be anonymous
you try to go the satoshi route um but
it doesn't work why didn't that why'd
you want to do that and why didn't that
work too many people yeah well so yeah
so basically you know been working on
this blockchain the diesel blockchain
for almost two years and uh we were like
hey you know we should really launch
kind of a prototype app to start testing
it like in the in the field so to speak
and that was bitcloud um and we wanted
to you know not really like have it go
mainstream until at least like the
middle of this year like the middle of
2021 um and so but you know we obviously
launching earlier is better and so we
kind of accelerated said okay in march
we're going to start sharing these like
password protected links with some
people just get a few hundred users kind
of see how the blockchain is holding up
with like this kind of activity uh and
so um
yeah so so what ended up happening was
uh it it you know kind of went out of
control and the links got like way over
shared um and to the point where i kind
of had to go out there uh you know i had
to start you know saying hey like this
is what this is and and this is like you
know what's going on uh but um
for me personally you know i've always
been
really
i think
i've always admired how like satoshi
kind of like launched bitcoin um without
creating kind of like a centralized
person that everyone kind of relies on
or like this is our you know our guy um
so it was really i wanted to kind of do
the same thing there uh and so i
launched with you know uh pseudonym
diamond hands um and immediately you
know it was kind of very hard to get
press it was hard to get people to kind
of listen to the story that that is the
real story versus making up their own uh
and so we had a lot of uh press saying
hey like this is a scam and by the way
because it was just a prototype there
were a lot of things were missing so you
couldn't cash out your money you
and i was like wait a minute so you're
telling me that there's a website that
you invest money in
you don't know who made it it doesn't
work a lot of the times and you can't
get the money out right and he's like
yeah i was like oh okay got it just
making sure we're on the same page here
yeah right rightfully so uh any any
other time i would say that's a complete
scam
also none of the code was open so even
though it's a blockchain and it was
running on a few dozen nodes like no one
could actually audit it or be like hey
this is a real thing uh so we were just
not prepared at all let me let me tell
you something
there was a whole bunch of criticisms
like what you're talking about right the
code is not open source you can't cash
out oh they scraped our twitter profiles
um oh there's you know there's a big
pre-buy people got in super cheap uh you
know all this stuff there was all these
criticisms of it we don't know who the
founders are you know they're kind of
anonymous
but
my theory and you tell i want to know
what you think about this so i have this
phrase which is i think emotion commits
the crime and then logic does the
cover-up so all these logical complaints
i don't think are the real reason why
people were so
like up in arms about this new project
that actually
is like a really net like it would if
something like this existed it would be
a huge net positive in the world and
those same people hate facebook well
this is the antidote if something like
this could actually get off the ground
and work and so um i was surprised that
the emotion was there and i think i at
least this is my theory
i think that people don't like when
someone gets rich without
quote unquote earning it and i think
what people saw is that
the insiders so the people who created
it or maybe the early buyers they bought
so early on the bonding curve they got
so early on and wow 100 million dollars
has come into this thing these coins
have run up in price or the profiles of
going up in price
and there was this feeling like
like i don't know i don't know how well
you did but here's my guess i think
you've made
tens of millions of dollars already
liquid without
at the minimum
and your project is like
under 10 000 dau or something like that
right so uh or under 50 000 let's say so
like in already in the tech world this
tech gets backlash because people will
raise at like 100 million dollar
evaluation and people are like oh i've
been running this restaurant and
laundromat for years and how does this
little app with you know with with no
business model be worth 100 million
dollars right there's already people who
get upset about that but but the one
saving grace is that they're not liquid
so it's not like the founders running
around in a lambo living in a mansion in
l.a but in crypto you're liquid too so
you you get the early hype and you get
the liquidity of the lambo and the
mansion and i think that that is
actually what triggers people about
crypto in general bitcoin in general you
know people who buy an nft and they get
rich you know they make a million
dollars off this random image um to i
think to other people that feels
inherently unfair
and so do you what do you think is my
theory what do you think of my theory
and then what's your kind of response to
the people who do feel that way i think
there must be some like validity to your
theory because if you read there's a
great book called the infinite machine
about ethereum and it catalogs like what
happened ethereum how it launched all
this stuff they got major backlash from
bitcoin people because of the way they
raised money where they were like hey
like you know projects aren't supposed
to like take bitcoin for you know
another coin like you know this is
like bad
i mean i read that book right after you
know kind of everything that was
happening with bitcloud and i was like
this is
eerily similar um so so i think part of
part of what you're saying has to be
part like like a factor um you know dude
look that said you know since then
diesel is listed on exchanges you can
trade it on blockchain.com ascendex and
a really big one you know a couple big
ones are coming soon and you know like
the code is all open and people have
gotten really passionate about it um you
know contributing to it the last couple
people we've hired are like open source
like they were just contributing to and
we hired them so i think that um you
know if i saw someone who's
very clearly a scammer
making lots of money i would be upset in
a way that i would be i wouldn't be as
upset if i felt like there was a shred
of them not being a scammer which we
didn't have because i was anonymous you
couldn't cash out the app was going down
a lot um
so uh whatever whatever theory there is
is probably exacerbated
[Music]
you